The general gonna experience when things get, you know,
someone's in my face barking about something, or, you know,
you get in the art world, you get these people that are really big pants,
but they would cower and she stood up. What do you mean in the art world?
Publishers, you get gallery owners.
So there's going to bark at you and tell you a way it is and you're going to do
this. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Really? Oh, telling you, man.
Tell me just,
I've dealt with gallery owners who are like super bullies who were like,
you're going to do this. I need this now. And you're gonna get it today,
tomorrow. And you're talk to you all the time and you go, Hmm.
I'm probably not going to do any of that. And the thing is, I like to,
I like to be super calm and it's almost like mind you Jitsu or where I go,
all that huffing and puffing you're doing doesn't affect me one bit.
If you want to go to sleep, I can accommodate that.
But we're not going to go down that road. And, and you know, I mean.
That's interesting. Yeah. And it would never have bothered the art world.
It can be a dirty world. I've had galleries that, uh,
knocked me off my own galleries.
Start ripping me off and producing work of mine out the back door and signing my
name, like making prints of your shirt. Right?
Wow. One fake signing your name.
Yup. Yup. Yup. Caught them, caught them. And then they said,
Oh no, we got that from China. And we're suing you.
And they come after me. They got it from China. They would make up.
It was all made up. Right. We caught them. And where was this gallery?
It was in, uh, Huntington beach really. And, uh,
we, uh, we caught him and uh,
we shut it down hard and then they flip the script and that's when, uh,
it was interesting because we were getting calls from a lot of media and press
and they were asking me like, Oh, you've been referred to as a,
you and your band of thugs went down, took all your art. Right.
So what I did is I flipped it. I said, I liked that title.
I'm going to do a painting called band of thugs.
Then I did this like old mobster, thirties,
painting of all these dudes and thugs band thugs.
And I'm going to make money off that. And, and, uh, you know, it.
Was a, is you have to go down there and get your art.
I went and took everything. I got my art back.
And while I'm taking all of it out of here, you're, you're,
you're no longer a Todd white gallery you're done.
And it soon withered and died after that. But, uh, it, it,
it drug out illegal problems and legal cases.
And how long did it last about eight?
Look at that. Look at the guy missing an eye. Oh,
just the.
And the thugs. Right? You want abandoned thugs? There it is. That's great.
And uh.
That's like some, uh, what's that guy? Uh, the butcher. Oh yeah.
Bill the butcher bill. The butcher from brings in New York, New York,
New York go to that big Hill. The butcher. I mean,
that is kind of how they're they're, they're they're painted like old timey,
bad people. Yeah.
Yeah. It was funny because uh, the Spanish hair did an article on it and, uh,
and, and they totally,
it's funny because vanity fair an article on what the whole scam and the whole.
Yeah. Cause it was, it made a lot of, you know,
she sold a couple hundred thousand dollars in fake art out there.
She sold it across international as a woman. Yeah.
It was a woman in international lines and, and it, it, it, it went on.
So she ripped you off to the tune of a couple hundred thousand bucks.
Oh yeah. Yeah. Wow. And it was funny because, uh, you know,
when it all came out and it was all court cases and stuff, I had,
I had galleries calling me cause I got scared. Like, Oh no,
I had galleries calling me in. They're like, Hey, we want to carry you.
This is 2012. Hey, we want to carry you. We to,
and I thought, what's this weird, like all this bad stuff's happening, but why?
So the guy calls me back up, art publisher calls me and he goes,
let me get this right.
You're asking me how come you guys want to carry you when this is going on.
She made you dinero and a Scorsese movie. And you're wondering why.
And I was like, he goes, play it up, live up to it. Go ahead and go. Oh yeah,
you can carry me. And you know.
What'll happen if you don't pay on time. Oh no.
It's just the ridiculousness. And uh, but it, you know,
look truth prevailed and it worked out and they're gone and I'm still thriving.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.